welcome to this video yeah this is some
a new part of the e4 e5 repertoire
series which has been on hold for quite
a while and the reason for this is that
by now the lines that I'm going to show
you have so many sub variations and and
yeah get complicated said that it was
really difficult to do this presentation
in the usual manner using this software
from ICC which is basically fine for
doing those kind of things but it
doesn't allow to UM yeah import
ready-made files with lots of sub Barry
Asians and this is why I want to use
chess basem for this and it took chess
base quite a while to learn yeah the
proof that I can actually do the videos
them with their software because it's
not um not a given you need to ask them
and they approved to do though that I
can do this so this is produced by using
a chess base 11 um yeah this part is
about the scotch for Knights which
arises some give it on the board already
here in the for Knights move order
Knight c3 Knight f6 on D form or it
could them also arise from the Scotch
move order with D form takes on Knight
takes and then at once Bishop before my
recommended move after which white can
respond he doesn't do so often but you
can 93 after which on I presented an
interesting alternative in Queen e7 but
so the main move has some Knight to f6
and this is a transposition to the line
that I'm going to show but um the most
common move order is this putting out
the Knights first and then this d4 move
yeah I recommend to take on deform
there's some actually a interesting
sideline with Bishop b4
I'm not quite sure with hundred-percent
sound but if you want to surprise your
opponent this is maybe an idea
looking at this move but it takes deform
them the main move yeah for more than
100 years so it certainly certainly find
here white besides the usual recapture
can also play Knight to d5 the Belgrade
gambit I'll have a look at this at the
end of the video because it's simply
entirely different from the structures
erosion arising after 94 yeah here I
suggest a play Bishop before it's um
also it's fits within the bishop with
the bishop before suggestion against the
pure scotch and water ended simply
probably the best move
um in 2012 this year Aronian played in
one game against kramnik who um - who
surprisingly employed this form Knight
Scotch in their match he played Bishop
c5 but he didn't really get them yeah he
go he got a very interesting position
but it's a question if it really was a
good position wipe replied Bishop III it
should be six and twenty-two with long
Castle a very fascinating game I
recommend her to look at this if you
have the time I didn't do a video on
this spell in 12 was very interesting
but Bishop c5 is some somewhat shaky in
comparison to Bishop before which is the
tried and tested main line for ages yeah
this simply increases the pressure on on
white along this diagonal so the e4 pawn
now is attacked by the knight I need to
get used to those arrows it's a bit
different so you put pressure on the e4
pawn and it's not possible really to
defend this pawn yeah in a mechanical
fashion so to save white would play the
move f3 which looks ugly at first um and
also the second look it looks ugly you
play d5 and
increase the pressure on the center and
opening up the position on against this
King on you one is some in general a
good idea
black can't castle really quickly get a
rook to e8 so black is better here
already on and this means um there's no
real way to defend this pawn jack you
can play Bishop d3 but this would of
course um yeah blunder oops
no not this I need to get used to this
blunder the the PCM so white really has
no choice he needs to take on c6 which
is the main line and basically the only
move yeah now if I threatened again and
white um plays Bishop d3 the natural way
to to cover the pawn um there's also a
possibility in playing Queen to d4 which
had been played in the the early stages
of this this opening like 100 years ago
or so yeah the black can play we kept
like Queenie 7 yeah still attacking
eform protecting the bishop on b4 + f3
now covers the pawn and like um has some
more than one good way to play this play
d5 attacking the center or also play
Bishop c5 winning a tempo on the on the
Queen just the sample line and um black
has some fine position um still even
this d5 movie is song it's very
straightforward and should be should be
fine black simply has pressure on white
center and this is not not too great um
cream defies basically if a good move
though this is played all the time um
yeah no black has the choice they can um
play various move so you can play d5
which is my recommendation and some
manuals there's also an interesting
alternative which I had
look at and was some yeah I was close to
to recommend this but I didn't want to
make it too complicated and there's also
the move d6 which is quite interesting
if you look for our less explored on
line then d6 might fit the bill the idea
is simply to stop the from the pawn you
to get a foothold here in the center
that white cannot play you 45 this kind
of thing and of course you need to get
your Bishop out at some point yeah black
um has some interesting ideas here
sometimes even associated with a quick
attack yeah going here and here
attacking the f2 pawn um this is quite
an interesting variation the only
problem and it's an important problem is
I don't think it really equalizes um
it's not it's not terribly bad but it's
I don't know it was a bit too shaky for
me to Trillium yeah give it as the main
main move here but it's interesting I
played it myself more than once
especially in blitz game then it's it's
okay it's just a bit risky but okay my
main line is d5 it's also the most
logical move attacking the pawn on e4
and developing the bishop at the same
time or opening it up so on yeah now
white um captures on d5 um yeah there's
an alternative with E 5 which this is
really good for black my G form
important to play in aggressive fashion
here attacking a5 not lying not in
Bishop Knight to d7 or something just
forward the ideas if white covers this
pawn then you can play an instant f6 and
break up the center something like e
takes F Queen takes it's already really
really good for black you know got on c3
on here and even on f2 that's pressure
so black is great um a nice trick after
f6 if white plays
a ch3 you can take the ship takes and
then Queen e7 and black get some yeah
already clearly better getting back the
porn and having a great Center on the
relatively best way to play for widest
castles and then you just Castle
yourself and this kind of position is
it's very comfortable for like you've
got everything developed nicely
centralized pieces the open-air file
it's some everything you would like in a
position um
yeah basically this isn't isn't to Grady
five and you know must never get it they
always take the idea I simply am
recommend to recapture there are
alternatives you could play also castles
which is a fun move recommended by am
yang Gustavson in this some DVD because
some yeah this is not really an option
and usually why just castles and and you
recapture transposed to the main line
this is a valid alternative it only on
the only idea of this only castle is
that if you recapture which is my
recommended move which has this this
check which is another problem I think
so I don't really know why black should
play this castles you can do it snow not
a bad move but it's not a big issue this
Queenie to check you can simply M
retreat to e7 with the bishop and yeah
then white has some to two routes you
can go for short castle or long castle
of here look at this Bishop g5 cancels
long castle they are of course them long
castle just can not without risk am
black has this kind of ideas on the B
file
yeah let's say C six okay one Bishop d6
h3 h 6o all very logical black has got
its pieces out and she will get some
oops I'm not used to listen sorry now I
jumped to something entirely different
where was the variation here on Black
has these ideas on the B file Mary Queen
a5 at some point and putting pressure on
those points and also they're simply
exchanges on the e-file I mean why do I
will never get them a strong attack or
something here um this is pretty
harmless really white can also cancel
short after this term check intimate so
after which black can simply continue
developing something like this and
there's nothing nothing to fear really
this is a bit similar to the main line
but it's questionable if the Queen on e2
is really doing white anything good
because black will get a rook to e8
later and yeah this mostly exchanges on
the e-file and the Queen isn't
particularly well placed them so this
check is not not really something to
fear after the recapture on d5 white
then usually castles and black does the
same yeah here oh it's an interesting
interesting point here the absolute main
move this Bishop g5 which has been the
main move form yeah more than 100 years
um recently however kramnik for people
who introduced a new idea probably it
has been played before but he sort of
put it into the the limelight he put h3
this little move yeah this is see you of
course useful controlling the the g4
square where black sometimes puts puts
pieces and prepares Queen f3 let's have
a look it's a rook e8 and then he played
a queen a3 against them Aronian um yeah
I'm not 100% sure what what's the big
point of this idea I must admit but
obviously I'm not 2,800
in mind in my mind it doesn't really
amount to much a possible line c6 Bishop
f4 and here on this position it will not
wrong Aronian played Bishop d7 right
yeah yeah brilliant played Bishop isn't
I'm not sure why he avoided the very
natural looking move at least in my mind
Bishop d6
usually it has a good idea for black to
get get rid of those bishops and some
without the bishops this knight on f6 is
very stable there's no possible pin with
Bishop g5 and so on and the only danger
that like faces if those bishops I
exchanged is that those squares might be
weak so white could try to get a knight
in there but this is not easy to do
I think after Bishop e6 like doesn't
have any particular problem
it's rather similar still to the to the
main lines probably am it is slightly
slightly improved version s in the main
lines very often white plays Bishop g5
and after an eight move like H sticks
drops back to f4 so what might save a
tempo but still on blacks position is
totally healthy it's some are too hard
to say what would whites big ideas in
the game on this crumbling Aronian game
Aronian played Bishop d7 and after a
three he took like ninety form but he
didn't really equalize if you just
quickly I don't want to get too deep
into this but look at this kind of
position this is not equal white Slon
enjoy some pressure the D file and he's
got simply more active pieces so black
black wasn't equal I'm not sure Bishop
e6 looks very natural to me it has been
played I mean it's not not a new move
even in 2012 it has been played four
times simply because um yeah after
Kramnik introduces a
three idea a couple of people jumped on
to this but there haven't been any high
profile players some with this position
as black some yeah players around my
strength like two for 2400 and they
reach life about fifty percent with this
move but sure maybe this will get will
get more popular simply because also the
main align with Bishop g5 which I'm
going to show now is some is simply a
very tame and doesn't really set too
many problems for black okay Bishop g5
it has a simple idea taking on f6 and
taking on d5 so black cannot play
nothing move like let's say we piayed
the problem is something like this it's
at an embarrassing so you need to take
care about the d5 pawn and you can do
this best by playing c6 this is really
um yeah the only move Bishop e6 um isn't
so good this has been shown quite some
time ago c6 is perfectly all right and
here white has some a couple of a couple
of options um in general it is not easy
to tell what what's the big idea that
that white might have in this position
black has got a pawn in the center d5
white doesn't have any pawn left in the
center so black has some a central
advantage with this pawn what white has
this has got very fluent development
very quick development got all his
pieces out this is nice and of course he
doesn't have any weaknesses it spawns up
all of the second-ranked so why doesn't
have any pawn weaknesses black it has
some weaknesses with this pawns and this
is evident here on oops on c5 and um and
deform their weaknesses possible
weaknesses it's not easy to exploit it
but something black must them take care
about
so I'm what I white loose now yeah
that's quite a couple um let's start
with the move like this rookie one
putting a rook in um in the center
um yeah black basically against all
moves except maybe Queen f3
you can play h6 winning winning a move
winning a tempo on Bishop h4 if white
would play Bishop f4 there's the
standard response with Bishop d6 this is
also why I was thinking about this
Bishop d6 move in this chromatic line
because like I'm usually M goes for this
kind of stuff anyway in the main line so
but that said Bishop at Bishop age form
then black can can simply develop which
should be six and Bishop to d6 and this
is simply a healthy setup get our pieces
centralized and why doesn't have any
particularly great idea um an important
idea to show is the following Queen f3
rook e8 and this is just to show a
typical idea before if white play
something like this you need to always
if this queen is on f3 sorry the screen
is the on f3 you need to be aware of
this Plus this possibility this
possibility Bishop to g4 um which of
course attacks the Queen and the Queen
is trapped yeah it doesn't have any
square the fun thing is if white and
it's the only move plays Bishop f6 you
play Queen to to d7 and trap the Queen
this is a very common motif also with
the white pieces sometimes with bishops
on d3 and g5 and now the queen is
trapped why can ya one can rescue the
Queen eeeh with the fun move Bishop f5
but um this is still good for black it's
not necessary to memorize this
particular variation it's just to show
this idea because it can crop up in in
similar lines this is also a reason why
as
schon chrome lick played this Queen f3
move in conjunction with h3 to get the
Sun square on g4 on the control rook e1
is a pretty harmless move it simply
serves no direct purpose um so what else
is there another popular movies COO 92
and the idea is to get the night to to
either here or to deform mostly to
deform yeah I recommend to play h6 gains
temple and Bishop d6 once again
um this has a very straightforward idea
if white ignores the idea plays
something like this you can simply take
here and win the game instantly not g4
check King here g5 and white can can
basically resign if I'm not mistaken let
me check this quickly yeah it's really
winning I'm I didn't attach evaluations
to our lines but this should be winning
White's King is out and your friend to
take on h4 and simply win the game so
this is one idea of this retreat Bishop
to d6 also to take on h2 White needs to
pay attention and one way to do this is
play h3 then you simply play C 5 and
avoid this guy to d4 idea taking the sum
under control white can also play in
Knight d4 which is the real idea of this
setup then you can react with c59 to f5
and then you simply capture and play g5
this is important need to break the pin
and this kind of setup is no problem for
black you first might think g5 that's
very weakening oops I'm sorry it's very
weakening but here those are from F 5
squares weak but the problem is some
white only has a bishop he doesn't have
a knight the bishop on f5 is rather
stupid piece it doesn't do
does the tech anything a night would be
terrible in fact black has some even
numb yet advantage of this position
white can probably hold it a very very
exact play but black is easier to play
now he's got simple ideas play rook e8
rookie 5 use all the dark squares go
into the six polling rupee eight or Ruby
eight attacking b2 like it's very funny
g5 is not a problem at all it's an
important thing to remember to break
this pin if Y doesn't have any Knights
left then this is can be a very good
idea and this pretty much also diffuses
this whole 92 idea it's really harmless
um instead of not f5 white could also
play Knight b5 but um you can simply
react by retreating to b8 c 4p should be
seven and like enjoy some just a good
game it's not not anything to worry
about but everything nicely developed
and something like this cannot really a
scab like and everything's fine even
proof i'd even prefer black here
slightly but probably it's still equal
so 92 is really a rather harmless move
that you want them to see what else not
a form for while this was popular um
quite a curious move actually the idea
is to put this night um on a square
where it has some influence on c5 which
i mentioned can be a weakness it also
prepares the move c4 checking this d5
pawn um I still recommend to play like
this this um still ism is a good
regrouping the bishop on before simply
doesn't serve any purpose anymore
oops this was the ICC
auto lockout so Bishop d6 and yeah as I
mentioned it doesn't have any purpose on
before anymore I'm if there's no pin
then the bishop is doing nothing and on
d6 it gets this Bishop takes h2 ideas in
and simply it's um it's nicely
positioned down so what could white do
here
c4 would be the continuation that fits
most with Knight a form yeah rook b8
puts puts it on hub opened half opened
file and here why it has more than one
idea but in general black simply
develops his pieces and needs to stay
active and interesting point is on Queen
f3 that you have this g5 move again
don't need to be afraid here because the
night is so far away from f5 look at
this Knight if it would be able to get
here it's something different but it's
so far away here it's simply concrete
play like is threatening Bishop g4
winning the Queen and yeah you can win
lots of lots of Tempe here I'd have a
five position at the end like must play
actively cannot turn stay passive g5 is
an important move to break the pin it's
worth remembering especially it
mentioned if that no Knights all night
like here night on the rim then g5 is
some it's a good move um yeah white can
play other things you can take on d5 but
it doesn't really travel black me to
develop pieces
yeah this is just down just a sample
line black gum doesn't have any any real
problems at some it's still a fighting
position it's not not to draw anything
it's interesting blacks got this deep
pawn and can can play with this but why
does still fairly solid this night on a4
though I'm not sure if it's really doing
so much you can go to c5 but it's not
clear that that is doing much good so
black is probably am just okay in this
night a form variations um just
something to add what doesn't need to
play see for immediately you can also
play a move like this after which would
be ages it's a good idea what what's
also I'm a motif to remember is this
Ruby 8 quite often it can be an
interesting idea to play rook before
I'm just don't let me highlight this
would be form attacking both the knight
and the bishop it's quite a funny way
for a double a check but this is also a
good idea to resolve this issue of the
pin on on the bishop so on white usually
place something like this to protect the
the light and like simply continues with
development and uses this idea as
mentioned to win a temple no I'm just
putting a couple of moves on the board
to show a typical continuation and dumb
black is fine here so Knight a force not
terribly dangerous but it's a way to get
a fighting position at least mm-hmm
which is not so easy to get a fighting
position if in this main position here
white plays Queen f3 which is the main
move and in a way also most logical one
getting the Queen
out putting pressure on on f6 here and
here connecting the rooks to allow rupee
one rookie to start again
um yeah hip like has some choice my
recommendation is to play Bishop e7 to
get some sort of fight going
um the theoretically best move probably
as h6 which has only one drawback and
the drawback is if white decides to take
on f6 Queen f6 Queen f6 G takes f 6 then
this position is almost impossible to
win for black I mean if you are content
with the draw and don't want I mean
don't mind them really dull position
then you can play this but just have a
look at this
92 like retreats 94 taking c6 Knight f5
and you need to hack this off and this
is the kind of position where you can
expect to as ydm expect to draw against
ya against anyone because it's process
is basically impossible to lose this
position um and it's super dull black
cannot do anything ever I mean white
probably also cannot do anything ever
but it's simply so boring that I don't
want to recommend this um so I don't
think h6 oh yeah should be played really
it's I mean it's it's possible as shown
but it's just down but it's very forcing
out I mean if you play against I don't
know someone who's 300 points stronger
than you and he plays this stuff ok you
can say ok then plays endgame it try to
show me how to win this you can play h2
simply because the alternatives are as
just nothing you should make for Bishop
d6 is fine and Bishop to h4 it's really
embarrassing man Queen doesn't have any
square what needs to play something like
ship c7 to avoid immediate loss and and
this is in
even great for ranking something like
this like is funny--i so h6 is very
forcing but also very dry if white takes
if you want to avoid this kind of
drawers position then we should be 7s
the move on I'm recommending breaking
the pin still um there are plenty of
lines coming that are drawers as well we
really need to be aware of this if you
fear you play against someone who really
only wants to draw and probably also put
in some preparation time to look at this
then it's really difficult to win but
you can avoid the drawing lines but need
to be cautious let's have a quick look
here what can white plain one waterline
is a ch3 here h6
you should f form if white ghost Bishop
each form then this again this idea rook
b8 with the tempo on B to the tacking be
too wide reacts and rook before this is
really important winning this temple on
the rook able to look on the on the
bishop so Bishop g3 Bishop d6 and once
this bishops I exchange them there's
usually no problem Knight to e2 c5 c3
rook back anthem like a simply solid
it's nothing to worry about just to help
the position with good central pawns and
why does it have anything usually he
just goes to f4 immediately as this
rugby eight before it some clear so just
Bishop e6 and that could continue
something like this we know this is
really logical logical play yeah white
tries to get something on c5 right then
Black has 97 and then c5 probably not
instantly but it's not them
yes if I was not them a point that white
can hold for for for a long time so also
nothing special h3 is a bit of a lame
move really yeah and then of course
there the move that put rocks on the
e-file very logical rook F to you one
for example yeah just rook b8 attacking
b2 this is this is strong it's the same
idea all the time and here of course on
white has some an alternative idea we
can play Queen to b3 I mean okay white
can play normal moves like like b3 or 94
and then you simply play this h6 look
before ideas it's quite quite similar to
what we looked at before just one
particular line Queen e3 attacking here
a seven and a seven and black can simply
play which should be six Queen a seven
is not a problem you can take B to
something like this and black is
probably even better already
so Queen e3 is not not a problem
rook b8 is the key really to two blacks
play here rook 81 this is similar but
much more popular rook b8 again what is
important and very common motif here if
black would play h6 which is not bad I
mean this is some the theoretically am
proof main move actually the only issue
is if you want to win the game it's a
problem white can take here it's quite
funny that is possible but it is
possible Y can take and play this one
attacking you seven and at age six of
course so if white um a text both it's a
problem you can play this one for
example here and now white threatened
a perpetual with Queen g5 Queen h6 and
black is in no position to avoid this
it's simply a draw funny enough and
there ways to lose the game even but if
you play a play mistake of course
blankets it's just a draw this is this
kind of line so h6 allows an immediate
draw so I try to avoid that and
recommend rook to b8 91 this is normal
at covering b2 if white would play
something like like this you can use
this pin to your advantage so 91 and
yeah here again
you can ask yourself what what next on
h6 funny there's still this move with
the draw so you cannot play that if you
want to win the game of course what else
is there at the end I came up with this
move there should be six just continuing
to develop and avoid this h6 move and
yeah possible continuation would be a b3
because you want to move the knight on
d1 in the future yeah again it's again a
slightly dilemma even here the move the
move h6 will lead to a draw
funny enough white can still take and
even take here and this is nonsense I
mean it's still a draw it's quite funny
this is still a drop black cannot avoid
this so you really need to be cautious
here with h6 yeah it's very often
leading to a draw of course if you don't
mind to draw it's no problem you can
play h6 in order to avoid all this this
drawing things I looked at rook e8 93
and g6 even g6 to take into take to go
to control g2 f5 that white cannot play
Knight to f5 and this sum seems playable
to me I didn't I didn't find any any
game so this is a new position um about
them it seems okay if you want to master
why'd you draw it or cost you can you
can go for this this is a in fact on a
slide problem with this line that for
blacks from blacks point of view if you
want to win the Scotch for Knights is
some not the easiest kind of opening to
to play simply because the center clears
up so so quickly and often it leads to
two quick exchanges of pieces on the
e-file and so on and there are these
kind of forced drawing lines with with
h6 like here where you need to be
cautious um yeah this is some the Scotch
for Knights main line I don't want to
forget the a great gambit it's not
played often what you should be aware of
this possibility
um yeah yep in this gambit black has
more than one good continuation I must
admit that I never looked at Knight
takes e4 which probably is risky um I
always played Bishop e7 I'm being being
a lazy person because we should be
having them get to a pretty okay game
for black without any any hassles
there's also an interesting option in
night before which I don't want to look
at now but which is analyzed in recent
books and seems to be okay as well
Bishop e7 is just just a simple move
continuing development by parry castling
and asking white what are you doing with
your knight on d5 yeah white now has to
to a main options Bishop f4 and Bishop
c4 let's look at Bishop c4 first again
you can think of taking me for when I
don't really want to I recommend just to
continue
galloping d6 and why them at one point
has to take care about efore recaptured
deform so it does that now 94 and you
can simply trade off all night CM and
have a satisfactory position this Bishop
on f6 is some a particularly good piece
putting some pressure on the diagonal
just the sample continuation Bishop e6
here to neutralize the b3 Bishop white
place this intending d5 with the
technology some new play g6 and black
has some as equalized I guess you are
very very close to play d5 and but I'm
sorry to play d5 anthem and to equalize
completely in the center and you can
still also keep this kind of formation
and trying to get something going on the
Queen side so no no big problem and it's
a pretty um
pretty solid position without any
director text which is always I think a
good thing to to have against a gambit
people who employ this kind of openings
are often very much attracted to wild
complications and somewhat dry position
is not too bad often okay which should
be seven there's also Bishop f4 which
shall at least threaten something
directly on c7 so you should just cover
this d6 Knight takes d4 and castles yeah
here if white wants to get anything
going he usually plays Knight d5 if you
don't do this black can simply get off
all Knights and set up a very nice
position with again a strong Bishop on
f6 and in this concrete position white
even as problems with canceling so black
should have a comfortable game
now b5 is the more direct move of course
here you can simply take it and then go
to you five blacks idea now is to to
attack the b5 night with the C pawn so
let's say you should be to Bishop f6
Ruki eight and at some point you can
think about c6 our Katie six or seven
yourself how do you don't do this some
do this so quickly just dumb Bishop two
to g7 maybe 96 you should be five yeah
their various ideas black doesn't have
any bad PCM good good if I'll play and
then should equalize really another
sample line is so let's say Queen d2 not
g6 and I hear here this disciple as
confusing the two lines here black uses
C pawn and this is even though somewhat
similar to to a Benoni
but black has some black has fine play
on the e-file and here there's even a
slight trick okay we are moved 20 I just
copied a couple of firm moves onto into
this line from some game the bag right
gambit dumb isn't too bad for white I
mean it's it's not not like you have a
disadvantage but it really doesn't
doesn't get much going if black gum
declines the gambit and probably M if
you really know the theory well you
could take it or play Knight before we
should be seven that's very simple
though I never had any any issues with
this some this line when I want to face
it it's very M very seldom that this is
played against you but if you know P
should be 76 castles just play normal
development and then be fine this is
perfectly alright so this was the Scotch
for Knights it's not the most exciting
opening in the world for black but I
showed them I think some ways to avoid
though
some instant draws which would there
yeah that quite a lot of them but if you
had watch those instant draws you can
still fight and get a long game to try
to win um in terms of equality this is
really not a critical opening the ruler
pests are some lines of the Italian game
or pure Scotch are much more dangerous
in comparison yeah thanks for watching
this video about the scotch for Knights
the next video in the 45 series won't
take so long like month will get out in
the next couple of weeks on and this
will be about the Italian game or the I
think JUCO piano let's stay with the
Italian game yeah thanks for watching
and I'll be back soon with the new
videos